how is everyone sleeping
how are things let's discuss good
sleeping well yes please
no nightmares no nightmares no no no no
no i am plagued by dreams
yeah what about you uh yes very uh very
very little sleep
currently
um the fan base for the comic books for
this are super passionate were there any
nerves
preparing for this
yeah definitely i mean i
did you feel it did you feel it
i
i understood so i've read the sandman
years ago and i understood that this is
such a beloved entity this comic i mean
neil gaiman's work in general people
like
will follow him to the end but um
i didn't feel that pressure because i do
think that the the
benefit of being sort of each and every
one of us was hand-picked by the creator
of this of this comic
the i think that is as as much as i
needed to go okay this isn't like
just some casting decision that was made
without neil this we have the creator of
the sandman so heavily involved in this
show and he's picked every single one of
us so i'm like if it's good enough for
neil
the rest of you you're gonna take it too
i also think that if
i think we all genuinely love the source
material absolutely
really speaks to us and we have our own
relationship with us and and if you come
from a place of love like that then i
think you
you could do your best yes i think it's
such a power of like the ensemble as
well like it's such an anthology um and
it's just there's so many kind of
creatives coming together um
uh as a as a group to kind of tell this
this story so i i
felt confidence in um
yeah in contributing yeah and preparing
for your roles especially playing
lucifer like how fun is it to play loser
i can't tell you how fun it was i really
really wanted to play lucifer i really
did yeah you know there's something
hugely enjoyable about being evil
there's something hugely enjoyable about
seeming lack of vulnerability
and and yeah tom sturridge who plays
dream is really fantastic really
detailed and present as dream he's
clearly done so much work on bringing
that character to life so he's very
respectful person and actor as well and
makes you feel safe so you're really
able to indulge in playing with cruelty
brutality and a complete lack of empathy
yeah it sounds so fun
and i know your partner the costume
designer yes um what was dinner like
um
chatty
like a bustman's holiday
no it was really fabulous because alan
um approached charles deacon my partner
about designing my costumes and i was
really delighted because
this was a a collaboration so we could
speak with neil about how he felt about
this new
version coming to life of lucifer um
giles he is my partner he's also
a
much celebrated designer who is really
exceptional at what he does so him
communicating with alan heinberg who's
writing the show with neil with jamie
charles the the director it was
and with me and knowing me as he does
and and there's pure love there in terms
of him wanting to
deliver
the best side of me visually that we all
can
and and to communicate really who this
character is in the most fabulous way
possible oh i love that oh yes yes yes i
love that um it is very hard to describe
this show
to people who haven't read the comic or
know nothing about it can you describe
it in three words or less
you had a great line before a
psychedelic fantasy it was a reality
through a psychedelic prism
exploring human i mean i don't know this
stuff comes out i've got no control over
it it could i can't remember anything
either
get it while you can
epic twisted fantasy yes
[Music]